[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and I've been planning
to make this video for a long time in
this video I will talk about 5 anime
that have genuinely changed my life
by this I don't mean anime that I
enjoyed watching and there are many of
those but rather I mean anime that
actually affected my life in a profound
way these are all anime that i rewatch
often and that i look to for inspiration
motivation and important life lessons
these are also all older and very
popular animes so chances are you've
seen at least some of them but I will
still do my best to avoid major plot
spoilers I will however have to talk
about the setup and some of the most
important themes that the anime deals
with so be prepared for that if you end
up enjoying this video let me know down
in the comments and if we end up getting
more than 1000 likes I will take that as
a sign that you guys want me to make a
part 2 where I talk about 5 more anime
that changed my life and now let's get
started at number 5 Death Note just like
a lot of kids who grew up in the West I
was exposed to anime through shown in
classics like Pokemon ukyo Dragonball Z
and Naruto but as a kid who grew up
watching these shows I never thought of
them as separate or different from the
other Western cartoons that I was
watching and this makes sense since many
of these anime were geared towards a
younger audience and on top of that we
had companies like for kids
censoring many aspects of certain anime
series to make them more child-friendly
anyone who knows about the Shadow Realm
in yugioh knows exactly what I'm talking
about the first time I realized that
anime can be for mature audiences was
back in 2010 when I was visiting family
in Serbia and randomly surfing through
TV channels late at night I couldn't
find anything to watch so when I came
across a cartoon I stopped because I
found it interesting that a cartoon
would be airing on TV after midnight by
this point my younger brother goes and
was already into anime and he kept
telling me to check out some of his
favorites so I decided to give this show
a chance the series was Death Note and
my brother had mentioned
to me before so I thought why not I
don't have anything else to do so let's
see what this is all about the episode I
ended up watching was episode 7 where
Light Yagami meets Nami misura and even
though I didn't even know the setup for
the anime since I didn't see the
beginning I was immediately struck by
two things first how mature this cartoon
was in terms of the atmosphere and the
themes and second how much it relied on
strategy that actually required serious
thought I remember thinking that this
was most certainly not a cartoon for
little kids kids wouldn't even
understand most of it and after that one
episode I decided to give the entire
show a chance when I got back to Canada
I watched the entire series and I
absolutely loved it and when my brother
told me that there were other anime out
there just as mature and interesting as
Death Note I instantly started watching
those including Code Geass Full Metal
Alchemist darker than black and many
more I was hooked I was an anime fan
Death Note covers many really
interesting themes including the concept
of justice and what justice really means
in the modern world as a student of
political science and philosophy this
was right up my alley and I thought that
light was an excellent character at
first you relate to him and even want to
root for him he is getting rid of
violent criminals and saving the lives
of innocent people when the system fails
and we all know that it often does Kira
doesn't fail but as the series
progresses and light keeps crossing one
line after another you have to start
questioning at what point Kira becomes
exactly what he is fighting at what
point does Kira himself become a violent
criminal who doesn't think twice about
killing the innocent as long as it
serves his own ends but the primary
reason that I have to include Death Note
on this list is that it was my first
mature anime and it is largely
responsible for my love of anime today
if I hadn't seen Death Note when I did
and if the series wasn't able to draw me
in even though I turned a channel to a
random episode and not even the first
episode I may never have gotten into
anime and I probably never would have
become an anime youtuber and you
wouldn't be watching this video right
now at number 4 Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood
long after watching Death Note I
discovered Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as it was one of the most
popular series of the time Brotherhood
began airing in 2009 and I got into
anime in 2010 the two things that
instantly grabbed me with this anime
were the great characters and the
fascinating world I especially loved how
Brotherhood brings together eastern and
western cultures and philosophies for
example the difference between the
Western alchemy of a mistress and the
eastern Alki estreno Jing is extremely
interesting alchemy is focused on
concepts like science and manipulating
nature in order to accomplish certain
goals and to gain power but all Kasturi
revolves around the idea that the earth
has a flow or Chi also known as ki in
Japanese which is life energy that
surges through nature all around us and
this energy can be harnessed in order to
heal rather than destroy in this sense
alchemy is focused of having power over
nature while alkis tree is centered
around living in harmony with nature
alchemists are interested in creating a
philosopher's stone while practitioners
from al-qaeda Street developed their
abilities in search for the elixir of
life and this is inspired by real events
in our own world where historically
Western alchemists were primarily
concerned with creating the
philosopher's stone which would allow
them to turn base metals into gold while
Eastern alchemists and Chinese
alchemists in particular were interested
in finding the elixir of life which
would theoretically allow those who
consumed it to have perfect health and
to live forever in fact the more you
studied the world of full metal
alchemist the more you discover how much
it was inspired by real historical
events and beliefs which is something
that I as a lover of history find really
appealing there are also many other
references to both eastern and western
philosophy in Brotherhood such as the
gate of truth which has many parallels
with elements of Western philosophy and
mythology and the concept itself reminds
me of plato's form of the good but the
one aspect of full metal alchemist
Brotherhood that I personally found the
most striking was the critique of
consumerism that is so clear in this
anime in modern society consumerism
refers to the idea that we should all
acquire as many goods and services for
ourselves as possible because in the
modern world we have plenty of resources
and commodities a lot more than we need
just to survive
we are constantly being encouraged to
buy more to take more to use more
billions of dollars are spent every year
on advertising products to us and we
proceeded to buy all sorts of things
that we don't need just so we can show
others how much we have in Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood the nation of our
mysteries is the embodiment of
consumerism it constantly wages wars to
acquire more land the ruling elite
especially embodies greed vanity and a
thirst for power and so on in fact the
homunculus are the most clear
representations of the sins of modern
society including of course greed Envy
lust gluttony wrath pride and sloth
gluttony is an especially point an
example as he takes consumption to a
whole new level and literally consumes
human beings without getting into
extreme spoilers we later learned that
human sacrifice plays a major role in
the series driving home the idea that in
society where consumerism is rampant
even human beings become commodities
even human beings are consumed in the
name of money and power on the other
hand our protagonist the Elric brothers
and their friends are shown to be the
opposite of the corrupt rulers of AMA
streets they are selfless noble and they
value friendship over all else they rely
on friendship and a sense of community
of brotherhood to stand against the
excessive consumerism of the villains
and this important message really stuck
with me as some of you may know I am a
fiction writer and I have published
several short stories in professional
magazines and journals I also wrote a
novel which I'm currently sending out to
agents in the hopes of getting it
published and alchemy albeit a different
type of
welcome me from the one we see in Full
Metal Alchemist plays an important role
in my book while I have had many
inspirations including anime books
movies and real-life experiences I can
safely say that Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood was one of the biggest
inspirations for my novel and when we
consider all of these factors it is easy
to see just how much this anime changed
my life at number 3 fooly cooly cooly
cooly is a short 6 episode anime that
has stuck with me for years
after I first watched it and it is one
of those anime that I love to watch over
and over again I even made an entire
twenty two minute video explaining fooly
cooly and all the themes and messages
within it but to keep it brief here what
I love about this anime is that it shows
us that the adult world and the social
and cultural norms of that world make no
sense
the show follows teens and primarily the
protagonist Nauta as they try to come to
terms with this senseless adult world
and its social and cultural pressures
and expectations all of us have at some
point been told to grow up and act
mature to be an adult and children are
all expected to one day act in a way
that meets our definition of what an
adult is certainly adult fans of anime
are constantly told that cartoons are
for kids and that they need to just act
their age and if you don't meet
society's definition of being mature and
an adult you are considered abnormal
like there is something wrong with you
however fooly cooly asks the important
question who is truly abnormal here is
it children who still have an open mind
who know how to be creative and think
outside the box who are not yet backed
into a corner by social pressures and
expectations or is it adults who often
lead meaningless lives and do senseless
things just because that is what is
expected of them by society in fooly
cooly medical Mechanica is a giant
factory shaped like an iron and it is
introduced right at the beginning of the
very first episode all the adults are
happy when it first came to town but our
young protagonists Nauta a sixth grader
sees it as a bad omen and heat
understand it medical Mechanica is the
symbol of the conformism of the adult
world it flattens everything and makes
everything the same it covers everything
in the smoke of everyday life and keeps
us from seeing the extraordinary things
in life eventually we learned that this
Factory appears to have no engine PSA's
or exits which represents the fact that
the adult world with its social
pressures and expectations is so
immersive that we forget that there is
even an outside world at all we cannot
leave the factory the machine because we
forgot that we entered it in the first
place the reason that many people find
fully cooley to be confusing and
over-the-top is that it features some
very bizarre things such as a robot and
other massive objects emerging from the
protagonists head but I feel that such
bizarre occurrences symbolize how new
and different ideas of the youth are
seen as bizarre by the adult world
the nonsensical nature of the adult
world seems to provoke a reaction from
the youth who are not yet corrupted by
it and now to us and all or weird head
portal appears to be directly triggered
by activities associated with medical
Mechanica the fact that this phenomenon
is named an O could also mean that the
key to escaping conformity is to just
say no to the adult world and its
expectations the key to escaping the
insanity of what we consider adulthood
comes quite literally out of the heads
of the youth there are many other
factors that I can talk about here like
direct references to the little prince
and other important works but if you
want to know more you can check out the
full fully cooley video the reason that
this animate changed my life is because
we are living in the nonsensical adult
world right now we live in a world where
money is all that matters where the
truth can be bought by the same money
through media propaganda and where those
who are already powerful get to decide
what the rest of us should and shouldn't
do when you are told to act your age
what you're really being told is to
conform to the rules and expectations
created by others
to stop being creative and to do
whatever someone else wants you to do
the reason that fooly cooly changed my
life is because every time i think about
it and every time i rewatch it it
reminds me to think outside the box and
not to limit myself to what the
so-called
adult world expects of me not too long
ago I finished a PhD in political
science and I have always assumed that
once I put that much hard work into my
studies they would pay off and I would
be able to get a good job in my field
but after I graduated I quickly realized
that this was not the case after
applying for at least 100 academic and
administrative positions that I knew I
was well qualified for I quickly
realized that what you know did not
matter nearly as much as who you know I
didn't receive a single interview out of
all of these jobs that I applied for
because most were simply given
internally to people who already worked
at that same institution even though I
was more qualified or the people that
were hired had years of experience
working that same job which is something
I couldn't possibly have as someone who
just came out of school if I wanted to
work in my field I realized that I would
have to work temporary contract
positions that pay much less and have no
benefits or guaranteed that I would
still have the job a few months from now
when I realized that I had a choice to
make take the contract positions and
hope and pray that one day in the future
I could land a more stable job which is
what the vast majority of people in my
position do or I could do something that
most people would consider completely
crazy and after getting my PhD I could
become an anime youtuber since I had no
stability anyway I decided to dedicate
myself to something I love and I put my
energy into building this YouTube
channel along with my brother goes in
even though many people around me either
laughed or were shocked by the concept
of someone with a PhD making videos
about Japanese cartoons on YouTube the
lessons I learned from anime like fooly
cooly taught me to think outside the box
and to be willing to try something that
most other people would consider crazy
today I am very grateful that I decided
to dedicate my time to YouTube and to
doing something that I genuinely love as
of this moment anime Opera has over 10
million views meaning that my work on
this channel has reached millions of
people from around the world that is
something that I never could have
accomplished with any of the other job
that I applied for and I'm grateful to
all of you who watch this channel and to
anime like fooly cooly for changing my
life in this way at number two my
neighbor totoro I am a huge fan of
Miyazaki's films in general and I could
make an entire video on how much I've
enjoyed his incredible work but to
Miyazaki films have really stood out in
my mind as life-changing those two films
are Laputa castle in the sky and my
neighbor totoro both films that i
rewatch probably at least twice a year
but for the purposes of this video i
will talk about my neighbor totoro and
if there's a part two then i will
definitely talk about castle in the sky
as well if I could describe my neighbor
totoro
in only a few words I would say that
this film is a celebration of life
Miyazaki is famous for how he celebrates
life by portraying both the environment
and the characters in his work in a
beautiful yet realistic way Miyazaki
seems to hate the idea of escapism the
idea that anime is something that you
should watch to forget your problems and
escape the real world even though
Miyazaki includes many fantasy elements
in his films he generally doesn't draw
his characters with massive eyes rainbow
coloured hair or impossible jiggle
physics when he draws nature and
landscapes he brings out the beauty of
these often ordinary scenes we've all
seen trees and grass and mountains many
times and the type of nature that we see
in Miyazaki's films is nature that we
could theoretically see anywhere in the
world
however Miyazaki is able to capture the
incredible beauty and majesty of these
ordinary sites and by doing this he
allows those of us watching to remember
to appreciate all of the natural beauty
that is all around us in the real world
My Neighbor Totoro is the perfect
example of this and it demonstrates so
clearly how well Miyazaki understands
what it means to be alive to be human
everything in this film flows
brilliantly the organic sincere dialogue
the story the action it all moves so
naturally just like life itself in the
film only children can see Totoro and
the other magical creatures because
children are still pure and
haven't been corrupted by the logic of
adults this is again very similar to the
themes of fooly cooly and works like the
little prince but the idea is that once
we grow up we begin to think that we
understand the world we have our science
our logic and our common sense so we
cannot see the hidden magic all around
us but children who are still
open-minded and willing to discover new
things can still sense and see the
things that we cannot interestingly
enough the adult characters in my
neighbor totoro including Mae and
Satsuki's father and mother and contas
grandmother are surprisingly open minded
to the existence of magical creatures
even though they themselves cannot see
Totoro they don't dismiss it as a
childish fantasy and I think that these
adults represent the type of person
Miyazaki is and the type of people he
wants us to be open-minded carefree and
children at heart
My Neighbor Totoro might appear to be a
film for children and surely children
will enjoy it but it is even more of
film for adults it teaches us the
so-called adults the importance of
seeing through the eyes of a child of
being open to the beauty and wonder all
around us and of not letting ourselves
be imprisoned and brainwashed by the
daily grind and the social pressures of
the modern world Miyazaki doesn't want
us to escape to some ISA KY fantasy
world full of bright colors and
gratuitous fanservice he wants us to
look around and discover the magic and
beauty of our own world he wants us to
be open to magic and miracles because
the miracle of nature and of the
universe is all around us and we as
humans cannot begin to understand at all
even with the help of science and
technology we need to feel it and
understand it on a deeper more spiritual
level but we can only do that once we
have an open mind it was a dream but it
wasn't a dream my neighbor totoro has
truly changed my life and made it better
not only am I reminded about the beauty
and
erricka love life whenever i rewatch it
but the majestic depictions of nature
have stuck with me to such an extent
that when I meditate and meditation is
something I practice daily as part of my
spiritual growth and self-development
I often picture the natural beauty
depicted in my neighbor totoro as a way
to clear and relax my mind in that way I
can honestly say that this film has
contributed to improving my mental
health and as such it has without a
doubt changed my life for the better and
at number one Tengen Toppa Gurren Lagann
this is the one anime that has changed
my life the most and largely for this
reason it is also my favourite anime of
all time well guten logon can be enjoyed
as just a fun action shown in in a
post-apocalyptic setting with a unique
animation style what I love the most
about this series is the inspirational
philosophical message that can be found
just below the surface in the very first
episode our two protagonists Simone and
kameena are in a village that is
literally in an underground cave the
village is plagued by frequent
earthquakes which caused widespread
structural damage and Simone's parents
were killed in one such earthquake
Simone is a digger who digs in order to
expand the village on the ground and
also in order to find treasures that
might be hidden underground
kameena is his best friend and is a few
years older but the two of them are so
close that communicant sitter Simone to
be his sole brother his brother in
spirit kameena is a rebellious young man
who leads the other youth of the village
to try to climb up to the surface and
leave the cave meanwhile the village
chief and many others don't believe that
there is a surface at all they've never
seen it the cave is all they know and
when kameena tells them that there is a
surface and there is no ceiling there
meaning they won't have to worry so much
about earthquakes he is called a liar
and a troublemaker to me this is one of
the best setups for an anime ever
because what we have here is literally
Plato's allegory of the cave in anime
form if you are not familiar with
Plato's allegory of the cave I will
explain it briefly Plato was an ancient
Greek philosopher
teacher Socrates was put to death by the
government of Athens for allegedly
corrupting the youth by teaching them
about views and philosophies that were
contrary to the accepted beliefs of
society just like coming now Socrates
wanted the youth to look beyond the
conventional wisdom established by
society and for this reason he was
called a liar and a troublemaker in his
famous book the Republic Plato wants to
explain how philosophers people who
think outside the box and question
conventional wisdom differ from other
people he gives us an allegory in which
a group of people have been chained to
the wall of a cave their entire lives
and they are chained in such a way that
they are always facing the same blank
wall there is a fire behind them that
they can't see and the light that the
fire creates projects shadows on the
wall the shadows is all that these
people know it is their entire world
their reality this is all they've ever
known
so they accept it as the only reality
because they don't know any better the
philosopher is like a prisoner who frees
himself from the chains and is able to
stand up and see what's really happening
he comes to understand that the shadows
on the wall are not reality just
illusions and he is able to climb up and
leave the cave to see what the surface
really looks like he sees the trees the
sky the Sun and so on the philosopher
then comes back and tries to tell the
people who are still in the cave and
still tied up just looking at shadows on
a wall that that is not the real world
but the people who are stuck in the cave
don't believe him because he is
challenging everything they think they
know in fact they call him a liar and
tried to kill him just like the citizens
of Athens killed Socrates because they
don't want their worldview to be
challenged they don't want to believe
that there is a surface at all a world
beyond the cave because that would mean
that everything they believed in their
entire lives has been wrong
kameena is the philosopher he is a
visionary who knows that there is a
surface a world beyond the cave the
others don't believe him until a giant
mecha falls through the ceiling of the
cave revealing the surface when this
happens kameena is ready and he inspires
Simone
to fight back
against the giant mecha using a small
mecha that Simone found by accident
during one of his digs together with
Yoko a girl from the surface who was
fighting the giant mecha as well they
defeat the mecha and leave the village
for the surface the surface is full of
these giant mecha known as gunmen and at
first Simone wants to return to the
village to the cave because he is scared
of this new and dangerous world but
kameena refuses to go back and he forces
him on to stand and fight against all
odds he forces Simone to reject
common-sense and make the impossible
possible
together they discovered that the giant
mecha are piloted by beast men
animalistic creatures with human-like
intelligence and there are also other
people on the surface fighting against
the beast men just like Yoko when they
defeat one of the mecca's coming up
decides to hijack it and pilot it
himself something that never occurred to
the humans on the surface but because
kameena is a visionary he breaks through
the paradigm he keeps moving forward
seeing what the others cannot see and
that is what inspires the other humans
on the surface to follow his example
they hijack other gunmen turning them
into weapons for their side and together
they form a human resistance force
against the beast men in order to
emphasize again the importance of all of
this and of Plato's allegory of the cave
in episode 5 Simone kameena and the
others who now follow them on their
quest to defeat the beast men stumble
into another underground village by
accident in this village called a die
the gunmen mecha are worshipped like
gods
and when kameena tells them that the
gunmen are not gods but merely mecha
piloted by beast men they get upset
because he is challenging their
long-held beliefs again coming up plays
the role of the philosopher who leaves
the cave and that returns to try to
enlighten the others who are still stuck
inside the cave coming a searches for
the truth and for justice and he cannot
understand that there are people out
there who are willing to live a lie just
because it's easier than accepting the
truth
kameena is an idealist someone who
always looks forward and yearns for
truth and
justise someone who is never satisfied
with the way things are with the status
quo some have said that communi is just
crazy and reckless and this includes
characters in the actual show and
viewers of the anime but kameena is
exactly the type of person humanity
needs in the horribly bleak and
dangerous situation that humans find
themselves in the caves and on the
surface common sense is not enough being
reasonable and practical is not enough
common sense says that they're all
screwed the beastmen are more powerful
and they will kill them all there is no
hope
kameena takes it upon himself to be the
symbol and the pillar of hope for others
he refuses to accept the so called
inevitable he thinks outside the box and
by seeing his example and following it
the other humans on the surface become
hopeful and confident that they can make
a difference
kameena is a visionary and the true
leader exactly the type of leader
humanity needs at this point which is
why others follow him even though
kameena seems crazy to some we have to
remember that throughout history a lot
of geniuses and visionaries were
considered crazy by most of society
Nikola Tesla was called crazy when in
the late 1800s he advocated for
alternating current as superior to the
more established direct current that was
being pushed by Thomas Edison in the end
alternating current one out and we all
use it to power our homes today Steve
Jobs was also called crazy for thinking
that everyone will one day own a
personal computer in their homes
way back when computers were the size of
an entire room and we all know how that
turned out and just like them coming I
was called crazy for wanting to leave
the cave for wanting to fight back
against impossible odds and yet he
inspired and mobilized so many others
and because of him and they were able to
achieve the impossible I don't want to
get into too many spoilers and I could
talk about Gurren Lagann and the
philosophy behind and not only for an
entire video but for an entire series of
long videos but the main point here is
that every time I watch Gurren Lagann
and I look at the actions of comic
I just get inspired to think beyond what
society says it's possible and to see
what others can see I am inspired to
leave the cave and to do the impossible
or what others think is impossible
because they don't know any better all
they know are the shadows on the wall of
the cave I try to do my very best to
make communist philosophy and outlook on
life my philosophy and my outlook on
life every single day what I am doing
right here right now in this video is in
large part due to the philosophy that I
learned from kameena and Goethe at logon
as I mentioned earlier after years and
years of University and finishing a PhD
I couldn't find a job it was a major low
point in my life and if I didn't have
communist idealistic and uplifting
philosophy if I didn't know to think
outside the box and defy conventional
wisdom I would probably still be
desperately searching for some academic
job that may never come if I didn't have
guten logon I never would have even
considered that after putting all that
time and work into a PhD I could make a
career out of talking about anime on the
Internet but here I am doing exactly
that good and logon changed my life and
it continues to change my life every day
as I do my best to implement communist
philosophy on a daily basis I may not be
able to use fighting spirit to pilot a
mecha but I can apply those lessons
symbolically to everything I do whether
I am feeling down about not being able
to find a traditional job or whether I
am overcoming stress anxiety and
self-doubt whenever I face a seemingly
impossible challenge I know to grit
those teeth and I think who the hell do
you think I am I am so grateful to the
creators of all five of these amazing
works that truly changed my life I am
grateful that I'm able to make videos
like this one talking about the things
that I love with all of you and I invite
you guys to tell me down in the comments
which anime changed your life in some
way
except boku no pico and curry in the
house because I think those two speak
for themselves if you enjoyed this video
and want to see me make a part 2 be sure
to leave a like to let me know if we hit
1000 likes I will definitely make up
- that talks about five more anime that
changed my life if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification bell as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see ya space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]